[Music]
I wanted to share just another quick
moment from my visit to James Harden's
basketball camp uh because I got to get
on the court actually and show off uh
some of my basketball
skills you can't see my Q card but it
actually says skills with a
z so let's check out my skills with a z
check it out everybody let's
[Applause]
watch who told these people that I can
play
basketball
through the leg watch
out I have to follow
[Music]
him it's a good thing you're good at P
shows good rebound Pete J it's okay even
the best Miss
sometimes if you think Pete's going to
win raise your hand
give him the drum roll this is Do or Die
For petees he can K granny
[Applause]
[Music]
shot